hello friends before I introduce today's
guests I wanted to give a massive shout
out to everyone who shared and supported
the episode from last week we ended up
in the top 100 on Apple podcasts
worldwide chart for three days off the
back of one episode which is absolutely
insane we've also now crossed 3.6
million listen min hits in under a year
so thank you very much please continue
to share the episodes tell a friend who
you think would enjoy them and rate the
podcast if you would wherever you're
listening it does massively help and it
makes me very happy today I'm sitting
down with dr. Rick Hanson who is a
psychologist and New York Times
bestselling author now what's
particularly interesting about Rick was
that he has a very deep understanding of
the esoteric meditation and wellness
side of the brain and how life can be
conducted but also has a very strong
academic background in science as well
so he is a serious contender for
understanding how the brain works and
today we're talking about resilient his
new book it's a very novel topic that
I've never actually thought of all that
much and relating it to how we
experience everyday life and how it can
improve our well-being was a big
eye-opener
and it would be very interested to know
if you agree so if you do or if you
don't drop me a message on Instagram
Twitter wherever you find me at Chris
relax but for now we're going to learn
how to be resilient with dr. Hanson
[Music]
dr. Rick Hansen how are you today Chris
I'm very happy to be here and by the way
please call me Rick or all to call you
mr. Williamson that's fine we'll stay
informal today so Rick what are we going
to learn about today what your teaching
is about well you've asked me here to
really talk about resilience which for
me is a word that's kind of easy to
dismiss like a cliche we've heard it a
million times but the essence for me is
how do you grow how how do you grow an
unshakable core resilient happiness
that's the question it's easy to be
happy when everything's going your way
but in the core of your being how do you
build up an unconditional well-being
that can deal with the challenges of
life and still feel content and at peace
inside so that's what I hope we can talk
about well that would be if I can come
up with that by the end of this episode
it will be an incredibly happy man so
many listeners will probably know you
for hardwiring happiness as a New York
Times bestseller right was there much
overlap between that and the current
book you're writing just released yeah
that book hard-wearing happiness kind of
you get it from the title it's the it's
about the fundamental how of growing
qualities inside the you that you care
about like grit or gratitude or
happiness or self-worth love for others
skills of different kinds in other words
how do we actually hardwire passing
experiences that are mostly usually
wasted on the brain but instead how do
we capture them how do we harvest them
and wire them into our own bodies so we
become stronger and happier in general
so that's like the general method how to
fish and then the book resilient is
gonna be a dumb metaphor here is about
catching 12 fish you know one of the 12
fish of 12 strikes that books about 12
strings 12 factors that are based on the
evolution of the brain is the kind of
framework when we get into the
practicality of it 12 strengths inside
that bring a resilient well-being in the
face of life one of the twelve strengths
is learning so that's the how to fish in
general and then the other 11 are
specific fish like mindfulness
compassion
aspiration courage that the book teaches
you how to catch in effect and weave
into your own body and so that you have
them with you wherever you go so that's
kind of the difference between the two
books I get you
so is learning the foundation upon which
all of the others are built yes and
isn't it true that that's the foundation
of everything you know I had this
experience when I was a teenager that
when I look back on it it was like a lot
of things that happen when you're a
teenager you blow right by it and you
hardly realize that something has
happened that's important for you you
know but you look back at it later it
was about 15 and I realized that I was
utterly unhappy I was miserable as
neurotic I was seriously messed up I was
a mess and I was kind of in despair in a
way like what am I gonna do my crummy
family my crummy school I'm dead in the
water no one likes me it was it wasn't
horrible abusive like some childhoods
are but it was pretty bad pretty
miserable but the light bulb went off
that I could always grow and heal and
learn and develop from here going
forward in other words I could learn
every single day how to be a little
happier how to talk to girls how not to
be such a dork how to not get so
bothered by my parents you know I could
learn and grow every day and that is the
essence of self-reliance where you take
it on every day how can I learn how can
I grow can I be a little happy or a
little stronger a little wiser when I go
to bed tonight and that got me really
really interested in that fundamental
process of how do you actually develop
yourself because then that's the
strength of strengths right learning
probably to find not memorizing the
multiplication table I mean like body
learning emotional learning social
learning spiritual learning dad is the
strength of strengths because it's the
one that grows the rest of them so if
you get good at learning go you know
then you can apply it to anything you
want to develop inside yourself or if
you want to help other people yeah I
think certainly for me the friends that
I'm closest with and the people that I
resonate with the most others that have
a passion for learning things and then
that's not restricted to academic
learning or useless fact learning it
virulent hunger for just wanting more
more knowledge or understanding whether
that be understanding ourselves and why
we operate the way we do or
understanding why there's debris from
the bottom of the sea on the top of
Mount Everest like you know you're just
just wanting to know stuff and I think I
feel very fortunate that I'm one of the
people that's wired in a way that I
enjoy learning however I definitely wish
that my capacity for retention and
recall was improved yeah
now if I could though as a guy I am a I
don't well I'm a total geek myself I
love learning of the kind of you're
describing and the kind I'm gonna focus
on here is in a way a different kind of
learning it's more up becoming in other
words becoming stronger becoming happier
becoming more patient becoming you know
more at peace in a deep and profound way
becoming more skillful with other people
you know the developing habits having it
be easier to exercise or not drink too
much or not be so bothered by other
people that's the kind of learning I
really want to focus on here with you
that you know the development of kind of
who we are as including the background
experience of living the development of
traits inside us over time because to me
as a guy who's well educated and I love
learning in an ongoing kind of way
day to day most of that kind of more
intellectual learning is interesting but
it doesn't have a big effect on our
day-to-day well-being or our footprint
on the planet or or effect on other
people the development of who we are in
terms of psychological traits of
happiness or calm or loving desert self
compassion grit things like that that's
what really affects us every day and so
that as a psychologist and as a
psychotherapist that's especially what
interests me also as a long-term
mindfulness teacher
spiritual practitioner that's what has
also really interested me you know in my
own path of awakening over this lifetime
Wow yeah so where do we begin where do
we start if we want to yeah we want to
develop ourselves into a benefit catcher
yeah we've got 11 fish and we want to
get them all yeah where are we starting
that's right a a useful framework for me
is to think of think in terms of the
three fundamental needs of any animal
which are related to the three stages of
evolution and the three levels or stages
in the brain and those needs give us an
overall overarching organizing framework
because if you think about it we are
resilient in the service of needs and if
we don't meet our needs we can't sustain
well-being needs are a kind of deep idea
in biology and then in psychology and I
think it's really useful actually to
move them back into the front foreground
of the conversation what are our needs
and to be vulnerable enough and brave
enough to accept the fact that you
really do have needs so needs three
needs safety satisfaction connection in
broad umbrella terms most of what we
need and want and I'll blur the
distinctions there most of what we need
and want falls into one of those three
categories or some combination so we
need to be safe rule one in the wild is
eat lunch today
don't be lunch today live to see the
sunrise right and then we also need to
be satisfied whether it's you know a
little worm that needs to get food or a
complicated human that's you know
seeking different goals and different
kinds of pleasures and trying to
accomplish things and be successful in
life and we also need to be connected
again whether it's a worm does having
sex with another worm or very
complicated humans dealing with politics
and grievances and tribalism and
attachment and the social emotions like
shame and inadequacy or feelings of
self-worth so this is a territory here
so we need to address our needs that was
so the first thing I would just suggest
to people is to
inside and ask yourself given the
challenges that you're facing out in the
world and inside yourself what are the
key needs that are really addressed that
are being tapped here yeah are you
dealing with challenges to safety are
you joining with challenges to
satisfaction to goal attainment are you
dealing with challenges in relationships
and then that takes you it's really
useful that takes you diagnostically as
a kind of roadmap into spotlighting the
particular resources that would help you
with your particular challenges so let
me be really concrete about it so I'll
do it kind of fast in a summary way so
you think about challenges to safety
they're indicated a lot by fear or anger
or feeling immobilized or you're
outgunned outnumbered you're helpless
so if in yourself or other people those
red lights are flashing on your inner
dashboard you know anxiety there's any
kind of spectrum including subtle
uneasiness or irritability anger or a
sense of being frozen you know you can't
you're up you can't do anything that
indicates needs for safety and it's
important obviously to act out in the
world my focus is going to be about how
do you act inside your own mind how do
you grow strengths inside yourself the
good inside yourself so to deal with
safety it's really incredibly useful to
know how to calm yourself down how good
are you at calming down
how goodie what's your resting state of
relaxation and ease inside yourself how
how rapidly can you drop into
tranquility it will those are key
strengths to develop another key
strength obviously is grit determination
I have a lot of background in wilderness
I've done a lot of things where you
really had to suck it up and dig deep to
survive that's a strength to deal with
safety challenges and then a third big
one is to notice that actually most of
the time you're all right in the moment
we're designed to revolution as you all
know to be paranoid right always looking
around the corner or what's about to
bite us or eat us or leave us and
instead the truth is most of the time
though in the moment of now we're
actually okay and as you develop that
felt sense of being okay in the moment
you're more able to deal with challenges
without having them invade the core of
your being I've done a lot of things in
rock climbing where it's really
hazardous but I'm not freaked out inside
so I'll stop right there I've spoken to
one of the three needs but that gives
you an illustration of what I think it's
really useful to do I totally get it
I really do I recently did a podcast
with Alex Hutchinson who wrote a book
called endure if you haven't read it yet
I would HIGHLY advise getting out yeah
very fascinated by that what I liked and
what some of the listeners at home may
resonate with is you are breaking down a
very overwhelming nebulous kind of
ephemeral global sensation of discomfort
which the sum is greater than the whole
of the parts sometimes and by breaking
this down into its component constituent
parts yeah you see them for what they
are and nothing more and you're also
given a clearer path as to what you need
to fix so I like the idea of identifying
what emotions are coming up
yeah then attaching those two okay so if
I am feeling X then downstream from that
what is it or upstream from that should
I say yeah what is it that's causing
that what is it that I need to
potentially spend a little bit more time
looking at I'm very glad you clarified
that Chris because you're totally right
I tend to make assumptions because I'm a
therapist long time you know that in
terms of self awareness but you're
absolutely right the foundation is
self-awareness you've got to be aware of
the fact that you're feeling uneasy or
so unsettled or anxious or you feel
threatened in some way and if because if
you don't recognize that then you won't
be able to deliberately identify you
know the tools you need for it it's kind
of like if your car has a flat tire and
you think you're gonna solve that
problem by putting gas in the tank
that's not going to be helpful you've
got to identify yeah that it's a flat
tire well I'll give you a little example
if people and a lot of people have a
background sense of anxiety they're
anxious you know we live in turbulent
times we're you know invaded by a lot of
media there are a lot of reasons
that are externalized that people appeal
anxious and also different groups are
being kind of shoved up against each
other that tends to stir things up and
then in everyday life people often have
a nagging background sense of am I good
enough am i performing well I get
everything done what do I need to do
about those bla bla so it's helpful to
look inside and realize you know if you
are at all nervous or edgy or uneasy and
and that often will then lead people to
move into anger especially men because
it's a way to manage anxiety to move
into aggression and anger but it rooted
there's an anxiety so here's the thing
if you practice gratitude will that make
you less anxious no gratitude addresses
satisfaction that's like putting gas in
the tank right but if you've got a flat
tire because you feel threatened by
something you're you got to deal with or
inside yourself you feel uneasy just in
general gratitude is not going to serve
you you need to build up those kind of
resources that I talked about previously
that are specifically addressed to
managing needs for safety so what's the
anxiety respond what would you recommend
this is someone who's got this kind of
pervasive low low level consistent
anxiety or unease general feeling of of
concern yeah which is 40% of the
population for sure stuff I'm sure it is
at least that I'm being a little
conservative because we're speaking
about a background sense of kind of
uneasiness or a tendency to go there
maybe it's not in your mind all the time
but you can go there pretty fast and and
then you have 10% easily the population
that are pretty clinically anxious well
the three resources that I named a
moment ago are really good internal
strikes and to repeat the point which
bears repeating this does not mean not
doing things to make the world safer you
know like put a stop sign in an
intersection or have a you know a good
criminal justice system or a health care
system I'm in America and we're working
on all these really yeah yeah we got
we're behind the curve set that aside
for the moment so building up the felt
sense
the visceral core of your body of calm
strength that's a really useful thing to
look for a you know a handful of
opportunities every day to feel and then
take the ten or so seconds of breath or
two or three to begin the process of
hardwiring that experience of the
resource the comp strength so key and
could you give us an example of that yep
okay so let's if whatever you want to
grow in the neuropsychology of growth
has to necessary and sufficient steps
first we must experience what we want to
grow or some factor of it
so we must experience calm strength if
we want to grow calm strength we must
experience skillfulness with another
person if we want to learn how to be
more skillful especially with a certain
kind of person all right we start with
the experience but then second
necessarily we must turn that passing
pattern of mental neural activation
think of it as a very rapidly changing
you know swirling Eddy in the stream of
consciousness that lasts only a few
seconds before it becomes something else
we must help that passing pattern of
activation leave a lasting physical
change behind otherwise by definition
there's no learning okay how do we do
that how do we embed it how do you yeah
yeah that's what hardwiring happiness is
all about that there are a lot of
there's a lot of detail about it the
essence is summarized in this great
saying from the work of the Canadian
psychologist Donald Hebb neurons that
fire together wire together that's the
two stages right they're firing and
wiring so if you want to help them wire
together three major keys first keep
them firing stay with the experience for
a breath or two or longer instead of
what people routinely do which is to
skitter on to the next thing especially
in our kind of jackrabbit EAD DEA's
culture and also where our attention is
being continually hijacked by other
people and attentions our most
fundamental properties so it's important
to claim your property and rest your
attention for a breath or two or longer
on the experience you want to
internalize because that's how you
get stick to you physically in part one
stay with it
don't waste it handful of times a day
too if you also want a turbocharged at
what's called as you know experience
dependent neuroplasticity where you're
helping your brain be changed for the
better in effect which is an incredibly
cool thing to realize you're doing you
are taking charge of who you are
becoming you are taking charge of the
brain change process so a second major
way to do that is trying to feel the
experience in your body
in other words move out of this merely
conceptual like an idea oh I'm a strong
guy you know that's good that's better
than the alternative but much better to
feel it in your body because the more
and experience is embodied the more of a
neural trace is going to tend to leave
behind especially with repetition
okay so feel it in your body and third
thing that's a great hack for your brain
is to focus on what's rewarding about
the experience
what's enjoyable about it or meaningful
to you because when you highlight the
reward value of an experience that
increases activity of dopamine and
norepinephrine to keep neurotransmitter
systems that then flag the experience
you're having at the time for priority
in storage for protection in the long
term processes over days and even weeks
of long-term consolidation into neural
networks of this experience
you're internalizing into yourself those
three things are great you don't need to
do them all the more the better
it's accumulative you know but those
three stay with it feel it in your body
feel what's rewarding about it will tend
to steep in your growth curve your
learning curve in general as you move
through your day so that is trying to
reverse the our minds are Teflon for
good thoughts and velcro yes that's
stepping in and you're you're strapping
some velcro to some Teflon there a
little bit I suppose yeah let let's
speak to that so you know my stick there
are two reasons to do what I'm saying
here number one this is how to grow
strengths and including happiness inside
yourself you have to turn
States in Detroit's passing experience
those neurons are firing you have to
help them wire into you and this is
profoundly important and people
constantly skip the second step in their
personal life or when they are helping
coaching or therapies etc other people
that's the fundamental process that's
worth doing in its own sake if you want
to help yourself grow and change for the
better every day this is how to do it
second doing this will compensate for
would you're bringing up here Chris
which is the brains evolve negativity
bias which as I put it makes the brain
like velcro for bad experiences but
Teflon for good ones and obviously we
need to register threats and I say I
don't believe in positive thinking
nothing and what I'm saying is about
looking at the world through
rose-colored glasses it actually what
I'm talking about here is old-school
it's about self-reliance it's about
becoming stronger tougher wiser smarter
braver happier more loving to deal with
the crud of life and as well as just
everyday opportunities so there are two
reasons to do this one to grow the good
in general and two to compensate for the
ways that mother nature wants to make us
more anxious and irritable and uptight
over time for bra purposes of survival
but most of the time that negativity
bias just creates a lot of excess
suffering and unneeded conflicts with
other people and within ourselves as
well I suppose
Wow so that's right we've talked about
how we can reinforce positive learning
how how can we dampen the effect of
negative learning that's a great
question well and when I say positive
only again really clear it's not about
just smell the roses that's good but
when we say positive learning we're
talking about becoming grittier becoming
more patient becoming more compassionate
for other people you know becoming a
more capable it because if as a point
that I guess a flag in the ground that
most of the listeners could use is did
that particular situation make me feel
good if so sit with the situation allow
it to like it like how you would smell a
nice glass of wine
right how you'd savor a you'd savor a
good meal you'd sit and you'd let it
percolate and you'd reflect yeah the
experience briefly for like you say that
the ten seconds or so that's how we
identify or that's one of the strategies
I'm gonna guess that we can use to
identify should I be spending some time
reflecting on this I totally true and
the reason I'm a little twitchy here is
that I've just learned in talking about
this that framing it in that way tends
to take people fairly quickly a new kind
of trivial or superficial take on this
waiting on so we frame it differently
though yeah it's legit we're saying why
not
obviously savor that glass of wine or
that moment you know with your partner
or you're just you know relaxing at the
end of a workout you know why not but
what I'm getting at more generally is
what do you want to grow inside yourself
these days what are you trying to
develop not just head learning like
knowing more things about you know the
universe but inside yourself are you
trying to become more patient more
skillful and so forth so one example is
I've been married a long time something
will happen with my wife we're having an
interaction it's getting a little heated
I'm getting irritated and I suddenly
realize hey Rick it'll go better if you
do X instead of Y and that doesn't mean
knuckling undermine to my wife or
walking on eggshells
I just realized oh I could be more
skillful in some way in the future and I
got to clean up the mess of this
argument but in the future I'm gonna you
know be more skillful there's a moment
there to help that learning land inside
yourself so that the next time your
partner is doing their thing and maybe
they're being a little irritating you're
not gonna react the same way next time
you've actually learned how to be
different you learn how to be more
skillful so that would be an example I
totally totally get it I think maybe if
my why was I was analogizing between you
savoring a nice glass of wine
and I'm thinking this is nice and you
feeling a sensation in your body after
you have done something which you
yourself value by the values you've
given yourself and savoring it in that
same manner that's it that's right the
savoring is a tricky word because here's
a another I'm glad we're getting into
the weeds here sometimes what we have to
register is not pleasant it's not
something we would savor like for
example if you recognize how to be more
skillful with somebody you don't really
savor that if you think about it also if
you're if you're like I was a shy dorky
nervous kid anyone a run for their money
as a shy so but then in young adulthood
you know I started doing stuff in
wilderness and I began having I was very
young growing through school so I didn't
realize I was at all athletic and I felt
inadequate and not manly and whatnot so
then starting in college and beyond I
did a lot of stuff in wilderness and
which I would have many experiences of
being strong you know even feral like oh
here on the planet or pulling over and
overhang or you know making a fire in
the rain and myrrh and I would just kind
of try to help those experiences sink in
because they compensated for those old
feelings of inadequacy and worthlessness
and they were also a way to build up
grit over time so now it's not so much
as I was savoring them it was I was
really trying to help them land inside
and shift myself along the way that was
the end that's it yeah that's a nice bit
of clarification that we've got there
for that so we like to say I'm are
warmer remorse sometimes you just got a
register that you were a jerk that's an
experience you're not gonna save her
healthy remorse the wince of healthy
remorse where you realize like I yelled
at our daughter once when she was like
two and I didn't think I was that loud
but I freaked her out and I just so bad
at the look on her face I just like man
never do that again
like you know that's something too we've
got to let sink in but it's not
something we would call
Saver totally correct I did a podcast I
think the listeners will probably know
it better than me number 14 or 15 with
Cory Allen and he coined this term a
chap salutely love and you may you may
like as well but you referred to as the
mindfulness gap and it's that breath in
between action and your interpretation
of it either from yourself or from
someone else and I often I often think
about that mindfulness gap when you're
talking there you're in an argument with
your wife or you you there's an emotion
or a sensation that are a thought that's
arising inside of you and before you
allow it to fully burst up from the
water as the fully formed bubble that it
is you just catch it and just think for
one second I'm just gonna use this
mindfulness gap to work out actually
what is this and what should I do with
it
it's great what you're saying here cuz
you're naming a second key condition for
what I'm really jazzed about which is
the general process of growth how do you
grow because then when you know how to
grow broadly you can apply to anything
you want to grow right and you've named
already two key conditions for that one
is self-awareness you have to be aware
like if you're anxious about something
yeah we're an easy you have to recognize
that because then you realize what the
challenge is inside that you need there
in a resource for the other thing you've
named here is that space of mindfulness
where there's a there's like a place in
which you can witness what's happening
rather than be hijacked by it and I
think of those by the way as two
fundamental resources also to grow
inside I use the term inner resource or
inner strength interchangeably
mindfulness is a resource it's a trait
people can develop trait mindfulness and
people can also develop the trait of
greater self-awareness you know by
exploring themselves over time and then
on the basis of those two traits then
you can really steep in your growth
curve as you go through your day I it's
very interesting that Iola well
obviously it makes sense because the
science reflects real life but it's
interesting that me is someone who and
my friends and other experiences that
were drawing upon here that uninformed
about the
ion's the approaches that we are finding
which are beneficial in the help I
reflected in the science obviously
that's it's natural but it's nice to
hear that that's that you're not you're
not come we would say you're not stood
in the wind with your dick out which is
in the mark so we mentioned about bad
sensations and oh yeah thank you for
that let's get back onto that okay 100%
so first well I'll do it this way for me
there's this fundamental three ways to
work with your mind just about all the
methods I've encountered as a therapist
and a longtime meditator fall into three
categories first you just be with what's
there you feel the feelings you let them
flow you explore them you have to
tolerate your own experience you just be
with what's there the second great way
to practice with your mind is you're
trying to reduce the negative you know
you're trying to prevent it in the first
place or decrease it or just well
release it entirely and the third great
way to practice with your mind is you're
trying to grow the good you're trying to
create it to protect it to increase it
in effect if your mind is like a garden
you can witness it pull weeds or plant
flowers let be let go let in in that
framework let be let go let in really is
clarifying so the first thing to do with
the negative is to let it be and I
suppress the negative a long time which
just made it worse because the brain the
mind is not like a flush toilet it's
more like a septic tank you know that
stuff so you have to be able to feel it
and that's where like kind of like
you're getting it earlier these other
resources inside of self-awareness and
mindfulness actually any enable us to be
with our own experience and not be
overwhelmed by it the thing is that I've
seen for a long time I've been working
with people for a really long time and
50% of the battle is
to be able to step back from your
experience not acted out not react to it
and witness it in a space of awareness
to be with it and that's half the battle
right there it's so important Wow but
then we need to let go so then I would
say this these three ways to practice
with your mind gives you a natural
sequence that maps to what's happening
in the brain as well so first we be with
what's there that helps it become
immediately less upsetting because we're
kind of stepped back from it we're
witnessing the movie we're not in the
movie and then we move into releasing
we're like you let tension flow out of
your body you you know you yell a little
bit not freak anybody out but you get it
out of your system being real maybe
they're ideas floating through your mind
that you realize you know I don't need
to believe that crap you know I can't
let that go
or you realize I'm getting caught up in
proving my point you know where I'm
getting attached to a certain goal and
it's just not happening I need to let it
go it's not gonna happen alright that's
the second great way to practice with
the negative and then the third is to
replace what you've released with some
positive alternative that's partly where
this idea of matching the resources
you're growing to the nature of the
challenge and the in terms of the need
that was addressed is really useful so
if you're letting go let's say a
negative that's more anxious and angry
you can replace it and focus on things
like calm strength feeling protected by
others relaxing your body if what you
released was more related to
satisfaction like disappointment or
frustration or a sense of your life
being depressive or blah you can then
bring in in the third practice
replacements that are things like
gratitude gladness healthy pleasure
savoring their good glass of wine or
that sunset or accomplishment that's a
really important one to register again
and again and again
successful goal attainment including in
small bits like each individual email as
you go through your day let Daddy yeah
or then if what you released I'll finish
so this one is related to connection so
maybe you're released feelings hurt by
other people or mistreated or resentful
or your
caught up in kind of grievances and
vengeance speaking of politics these
days but anyway
and instead of you know so after you've
released that what do you replace it
with you replace it with self-worth or
feeling cared about or connected with
other people or you grow compassion or
self compassion or confidence that are
specifically related to negative
material related to connection sorry so
those three give you a great roadmap for
dealing with stuff in the moment and if
you want to as a bonus you can do what I
call linking in which you're aware of
both positive and negative in your mind
at the same time you have to keep the
negative small and off to the side like
old feelings of hurt or feelings of
resentment and then in the foreground of
your awareness you focus on the positive
material the beneficial material that's
kind of the matched antidote to that
negative so you would be let's say my
example aware simultaneously a feeling
kind of hurt off to the side like
ignored dismissed disrespected but in
the foreground you would be really aware
of people who like you your buds your
buddies your comrades you know your
friends your allies who really care
about you and love you and since neurons
that fire together wire together when
you're where two things at once
especially if you keep the positive
bigger it will gradually soothe and ease
and even replace the negative material
over time that's that's a very nice
prescriptive framework for for dealing
with thoughts that arise I'm currently
reading five ways to know yourself by
Shinzon Jung oh I know Shen Zhen he's
the real deal
Shinzon is a is yeah he's definitely the
real deal that's a great way to put it
so I'm currently reading five ways to
know yourself and anyone who anyone else
who's read Shinzon's
work will know that he cites suffering
as pain times resistance actually any
pain times resistance but what you have
to remember is that that is pain to the
power of resistance because it's not
pain plus resistance it's for each
element of pain that you have it is
multiplied by how much you resist it and
what I I like about the
you've come up with they're about being
with the thoughts and about allowing
them to sit in your mind and not
resisting them is that it restricts this
down to its smallest possible number
that's exactly right and there's a
teaching and students Buddhist and you
know I am as well and you know he would
certainly know this the Buddha made this
great distinction between the first dart
in the second dart you know the first
start is there's a Buddhist saying you
know pain is necessary suffering is
optional in other words in life there
are gonna be things that happened
physical pain social pain but that's the
primary experience in and of itself it's
not so bad if we don't fight it just
like you're saying it's when we fight it
that we add the second third fourth
fifth darts of our own reactions and
that's where the bulk of our suffering
really comes from I think as well and
the listeners at home will probably know
know this sensation as well is the the
awful kind of Bayesian updating gone
wrong an echo chamber that is you
getting irritated by something and then
very quickly getting irritated by
getting irritated yeah very soon you've
forgotten what you got irritated by and
your irritation at your irritation is
just this self-sustaining kind of like a
unlimited energy machine that carries
you through the next however long until
something else comes and kind of
sideswipes out of the way I know and so
much of that I call it being lost in the
simulator you know we have these recent
neural evolution in the middle and and
the cortex on top that is like a virtual
world we're sucked into these little
mini movies and did you know probably a
lot of research says the more you're
sucked into the simulator or you could
call it the ruminator or you just sort
of disconnected from the present moment
lost in your own little mind movie the
more people tend to be lost in the
simulator the more saturated with
negative emotion they tend to be yeah I
love ruminated I'm gonna I'm gonna have
to coin that so I think what might be
nice we've talked about a lot of the
stuff is it is quite prescriptive but
still conceptual and
application actually getting after it
and having some tassets strategies for
how people can potentially implement
some of this stuff is it's going to be
key so are there some habits or routines
or approaches which can be easily
understood and easily applied that the
listeners may be able to take away -
sure oh yeah I mean the one thing I
would bang on is get interested in
growing in other words get interested in
the process of growth itself it's
weirdly difficult Chris for people to
focus on the process of growing even
though it's obviously logically
everybody would go oh yeah that's that's
that's the most important thing to get
good at get good at growing right
because then I can grow whatever else I
want to grow get good at growing but a
lot of people don't pay much attention
to actually the process of helping
learning land especially emotional
learning you know body learning you know
so that would be a restaurant of
suggestion for people may seem abstract
but it's right in the middle of everyday
you know when you go to bed are you any
wiser any stronger and he happier than
when you woke up so that would be a key
suggestion then I would say a second
thing if I could be kind of very
concrete less than 10 minutes a day if
people did what I'm about to say you
would totally change their life and all
and I'll put it out as a challenge and
you tell me if I'm wrong first three
things first as you go through your day
half a dozen times a day a handful of
times each day slow down for a breath or
two or three to take into yourself
something beneficial that you're
experiencing something that's useful
something that feels good some coming
home to a calmer happier place inside
you know a connection with a friend you
finish a task you get the kids in bed
finally you look at the sunset slow it
down for a breath or two or three right
okay that's a minute or two add a second
pick one thing you're trying to grow in
yourself these days that's of an inner
strength that matters to you like
one thing I'm trying to do myself is
build up more and more of the habit of
complete patience in the moment even at
a pretty subtle level so I'm working on
that
I'm going after that you know and well
that's what is it you know my wife's
working on not being so anxious about
stuff you know different people are
working on different things what are you
trying to develop in yourself know one
thing that you're trying to grow each
day and then look for in the two stages
of learning opportunities to experience
it that second you take into yourself
right that will organize your day and
give you hope because no matter how
tough the world is if you know you're
focused on developing yourself that kind
of organizes what you're doing and then
the third thing I would suggest which
really goes to our animal nature and the
ways in which deep down inside each one
of us is a little lizard mouse and
monkey related to the brain stem sub
cortex and neocortex and the three
stages of evolution you know for a few
minutes every day drop into what I call
deep green the deep green zone where
your body and mind feel deeply peaceful
contented and loved and loving in terms
of the three needs and rest in that for
two or three or five minutes in a row to
really
hardwire it into your body and then is
actually what I just described there
that felt sense of safe enough satisfied
enough and connected enough marked by a
feeling broadly of peace contentment and
love that home-baked that's our home
base biologically mother nature's plan
is for her little creatures to rest in
the deep green most minutes of most days
because that's how you conserve
biological resources stay out of trouble
you know and that's your best odds
strategy for a long and happy life
problem is in modern life most people
are jostled out of that home base by
low-grade but chronic mild to moderate
stressed yeah and so yeah so what I'm
describing three to five minutes a day
is a training where you're training a
visceral core of your body your heart
rate your lungs
your belly your gut the core of your
being to rest in this place of deep
strong well-being
I didn't mean so all right 10 minutes a
day that's it that's it alert do it for
three days in a row you'll feel really
different condition or well change your
life that's fantastic for the listeners
at home if you listened to I want to say
life hacks 105 which is round about a
month ago Youssef mentioned an app which
is called remembered have you heard of
this right no but I like the idea so
every little icon is a bit of string
around someone's finger and the it's
essentially just a reminder that which
you could use on your phone but this
one's a little bit different in the you
sets daily repeated reminders or you can
set them at periods throughout the day
and what Youssef likes to use it for
which is relates nicely to the strategy
that you just mentioned there is he has
a very particular sound it's got a
library of just like chimes and stuff
but it doesn't sound like a text message
it's a very specific kind of sound and
it's sound that you will know and that
you can relate to whatever it is that
you're trying to do so for instance at
the moment Youssef is trying to focus on
deepening the breath on breathing into
his Dunton which is a below label and
what he's using it for is whenever it
goes off I think it maybe three or four
times a day
it's this weird little chime that no
anyone else in the room will think it's
an email or it whatever but he knows
that it's focused on the breath and
using that app it's free to download and
you know if you were to try and come up
with a solution to remind yourself to do
something a couple of times a day that's
a great option there I've got a couple
of questions that's been kind one of
them's been burning since the beginning
and you've almost touched upon it there
you mentioned that our our zero-point
setting our natural setting as animals
is to be in this deep green where we
feel safe and content and connected I
would wager that the vast majority and
this is kind of a sad comment I guess
but the vast majority of the listeners
will think that sounds pretty alien to
me like
yeah that that status that living status
doesn't sound like it that sounds like
why aim to achieve not and not what I
own on a day-to-day basis so firstly do
you think it's possible to live a
consistent life that is in that state
and then second thing the question the
question I've had burn it's been written
at the very top of my notes since we've
been talking is in if you were to take
humans from 5000 years ago
mmm-hmm how do you think their feelings
of satisfaction and daily happiness
would compare with us now and why do you
think it might be different man Chris I
just filled these topics and questions
are right at the heart of the personal
and the political know their word so
right at the heart at the personal
well-being and functioning and they're
right at the heart of what our species
is dealing with in the 21st century so
I'll try not to blather on so first off
let's I'll make two points one if you
want to get good at something study
people who are really good at it right
so I've done a lot of rock climbing and
I'll watch people who are much better
climbers in me and I'll imagine moving
in my own body like them and then when I
go up on the cliff I climb better
alright study people who are really good
at things in the same way if we want to
get good at happiness and functioning so
we want to be able to operate at a high
level while simultaneously feeling
really good inside and being good in our
relations with others I think that
people would like that well study the
people who really developed that and
really embody that and generally they
tend to be people who've done a lot of
inner practice you know they're just
something about Shinzon here I'm way we
just everyone needs to sit in a circle
and [ __ ]
Shinzon can be in the middle and we can
just all look at him well sure or think
about that lady
think about who taught your preschool
when you were in kindergarten sometimes
a lot of the people that are real
far along in their practice they're not
famous and they're not even
quote-unquote spiritual but how do they
do it
how do they do it so you reverse
engineer that's what I'm getting at how
do you reverse engineer enlightenment
reverse engineer peak functioning or
self actualization reverse engineer it
and including in the body right so if
you look out at the world there clearly
are people who in the face of enormous
challenge oppression discrimination
racism refugee camps the worst of the
worst
still in the core of their being you can
just tell there's an inner peace and
inner calm they hold on to their love
they don't get corroded by hate it's
possible so the key point is it's
possible how do they do it
right okay point one point two there's
this great great quotation from Robert
Sapolsky the researcher on stress you
may know it he says most episodes of
stress in the wild and quickly one way
or another in other words most stressed
in the wild is brief you know an animal
is attacked it either escapes or a
doesn't it ends quickly one way or
another and the problem is that modern
humans we don't end our stress episodes
quickly so the natural resting state is
to really be centered into this feeling
of biological well-being in which
there's enough food you know we're
looking around or making sure no lions
are attacking we're okay we're rubbing
up against the other zebras maybe we'll
get lucky tonight
or hey it's okay and it's great to
appreciate that that's our home base
that rather there's a long debate what
is human nature I think we have two
nature's you know Green Zone red zone
the green zone is our deepest nature
because it's our resting state the
resting state of a dynamic system is
what most characterizes it our resting
state when needs feel sufficiently mad
is the body calms down and the mind
defaults to a sense of peace contentment
and love that's a key point
and so through internalizing repeated
experiences that are authentic of the
felt sense of needs met sufficiently we
grow we build out this green zone core
inside ourselves which then makes us
more able in a positive cycle to meet
our needs without getting sucked into
upsetting stress we're able to deal with
the world from this unshakable core of
resilient well-being and that makes all
the difference in the world so for me
that key question does to summarize is
how do we face the challenges of life
without getting invaded and hijacked
into the redzone of fear in terms of
safety frustration in terms of
satisfaction and hurt or resentment or
vengeance in terms of connection issues
how do we do that and I think the
possibility is to move through each day
deliberately as individuals growing the
strengths inside so that more and more
we are like these people who are models
exemplars Nelson Mandela the Dalai Lama
chin done yeah or your kindergarten
teacher who is always patient no matter
what [ __ ] you know the parents work
well not alone the kids you know and
that to me is the great opportunity
that's realistic in this life and to
develop this increasingly unshakable
core in which in your essence you're
fine no matter how much crap you're
dealing with so what we've one point
there that leads us quite nicely on to
that final question about about humans
that have been around a long time ago is
that you mentioned that a systems
natural state what was it systems
natural state is the one which it's most
comfortably the resting the what it's
interesting to think about it imagine a
mobile in a breeze moving lightly right
it's a dynamic system what most
characterizes a dynamic system it's not
what it goes into when it's disturbed
because that's just an outer bound state
it's its resting state that most
characterizes a dynamic system you could
think also of a thermos
setting in your own and Celsius let's
say you set it at 20 Celsius that is the
resting state around which the
temperature varies by a degree or two
but so you would not say if you were
saying what's the you know how would you
characterize the temperature in your
home you'd say was 20 degrees you know
it's the resting state the resting state
of human beings is where we go and also
other animals it's where we go when
needs are met and where we go or what
needs are met is a really good place
most people when they feel an enoughness
of safety satisfaction and connection
become nicer though they become more
generous
Almer they're happier they become more
ambitious they also look around for more
things to fix in the world they don't
just sit on you know their cushion and
eat bonbons chanting ohm you know they
want to help it's when people are as you
said drawn into what I call inner
homelessness where they're not in touch
with our core they're not in this
resting state they feel kind of
desperate inside they feel uneasy and
frustrated and disconnected that's when
people develop long term health issues
that are stress based but also that's
when people are vulnerable to the
classic manipulations of authoritarian
leaders yeah we have the answer so why
is it in that case if that's our natural
state if that's the dynamic system is
supposed to be firstly why is it that so
few people feel that in the modern world
and secondly if we're talking to Rick
Hansen's great great great ^ twenty-five
grandfather from 5,000 years ago how do
you think what what do you think his
mindsets like it's a great question so
the the key answer to that is they're
basically humans have two natures so one
there's our resting state I call it the
Green Zone for simplicity but we also
and our animal cousins the monkeys of
mice and the lizards also have a second
nature the red zone which is fast
response stress response in which we
fire up into fighting fleeing or
freezing we are very vulnerable to
getting triggered into a burst of red
zone stressful activity mother nature's
blueprint is that those episodes of red
zone fight flight freeze stress activity
are supposed to end quickly and then
we're supposed to return to the Green
Zone for a long period of recovery and
you can look out into nature and you can
see that most of the time that's the
template out there in nature all right
the problem is in modern live conditions
since agriculture came in ten thousand
or so years ago we chronically are
pushed into red zone situations
including a modern life you know we're
modern we have refrigerators we have
pain medication and all the rest of that
and yet you're exactly right
I think most people are jostled into
low-grade mild to moderate stress every
day which is not their home base in
which accumulates wear and tear on their
body why drink why do you think that's
happening what's guess I think the deep
roots of that are in wealth inequality
since agriculture came in I think that
constructed the socially constructed
sources of chronic mild to moderate
stress are largely rooted in
inequalities of wealth and power that
emerged after agriculture enabled our
ancestors 10,000 years ago to accumulate
surpluses and then cities and all the
rest of that the deep causes because if
you think about it the way that society
operates today is a vast departure from
the hunter-gatherer template and I want
to be really clear I like my modern
conveniences I like pain control I like
a cold beer me too I like I like ESP ed
you don't well you're in it when I'm
here or wherever you are you know we're
communicating I love that stuff but the
problem is just look at it in a
hunter-gatherer band that's the natural
template for human politics and life
that's a band of 50 people about 30
adults most of whom you know your entire
life now just think about that
as the ways in which we evolved until
barely just 10,000 years ago for 300,000
years of our species another 2 million
years of tool manufacturing ancestors
close relatives that's the template a
small band of 30 to 50 people
interacting with other bands many of
whom are dangerous because we're
competing for scarce resources so we
need to cooperate internally and be
fearful and aggressive externally much
of the time that's our template in those
bands so bear with me briefly there are
three conditions enabled healthy
politics common truth you couldn't hide
the facts you saw you know when you live
together with people day in and day out
you see the truth you know is lying you
know is trustworthy you know is legit
you know where the money you know you
know who's eating more food and sneaking
some food away from the group you you
know who's screwing who you know you
know what's going on in a
hunter-gatherer band but when you start
having agriculture and big cities and
Game of Thrones and even modern life you
can hide the truth and in fact in modern
times we have people who attack
truth seeking and truth protecting but
in hunter-gatherer bands there's common
truth there's also common welfare you
know there are minor inequalities of
wealth and power and under gatherer ban
but on the whole your kin you are
relatives and also because you're a band
you really need each other so if you go
down that hurts me on the other hand if
you prosper that helps me so we have
common welfare we're really tied
together again in a way that is not the
case because since surpluses came in and
inequalities of wealth and power that
our big rich people can get richer
doesn't trickle down how people kind of
can have a famine it doesn't mean that
it infects the people behind the castle
walls totally right yeah the quote from
the Bible which is from those who have
nothing more will be taken from those
who have everything more will be given
it's it's a very very old concept one
part one last thing you don't have
common justice
the third condition in a hunter-gatherer
band
common truth common welfare is common
justice you know the leaders their
leaders they have power but eventually
honestly if our band had a leader he was
a jerk after a season or two you and I
as some other men would go welcome me or
we just say see you later [ __ ] we're
gonna form a new band politics would
change but now you don't have common
justice you have rich man's law a poor
man's law so for me the summer is a lot
of this stuff the challenge in the 21st
century is how with seven billion plus
interconnected people can we recreate
the objective conditions for healthy
human politics healthy human governance
which is common truth common welfare and
common justice and if we can lay that
foundation which you see some societies
like the EU imperfectly
the UK imperfectly you know are moving
in that direction but you can also see
that elites that are wealthy and want to
protect their wealth and power they
attack these three conditions common
truth common wealth or common justice
because that's what enables them to
continue living their sweet life to
their own advantage but to the
disadvantage of the great majority of
other humans would that be so I agree
with all of your points however the the
thing that sticks out in my mind is that
I don't think that the people who were
at the top of the tree are unbelievably
happy either
so the yeah so it's not like I I don't
I'm sure that there's a lot of people
who were very wealthy and very
successful who feel even worse than the
the proletariat like downing it down in
the streets so I think you're right and
that gets to a really deep point which
is we can't just fix the object of
conditions we need to internalize the
feeling of needs mad otherwise you're
right
where I grew up in LA around there
really Hills the Tibetan metaphor is the
hungry ghosts you know who have godlike
powers and enormous appetites but they
can't satisfy their appetites and I
agree that does seem to be the case with
a lot of people caught up in wealth and
fame they're not deeply contented and to
me the trick is to be able to do both is
to be reasonably you know have like a
to not live in grinding poverty to have
good medical care to have enough food
you know a billion humans go to bed
hungry every night in this planet today
in America in my country a million
children go through homelessness every
year you know one in four one in five
children in America lives below the
poverty line and has to face hunger not
infrequently so yeah we need to do those
things but on the other hand if we don't
have a transformation of the heart
if we don't internalize the felt sense
of safe enough satisfied enough
connected enough then we're always
hungry then we're caught up in the
Buddha second noble truth of craving and
we're always chasing and trying to pile
up our possessions and build up our
Empire frankly look at Donald Trump the
epitome of a Hungry Ghost someone who
has everything and yet you could see it
in his face he's miserable inside an an
is and in his own search for a lasting
happiness which he's never found he's
harming lots of other people we've got
that hedonic treadmill again haven't we
which the listeners will have heard us
mentioned before as you begin to your
body begins to renormalize to whatever
increased state of nicer possessions is
the you get the new car and then after a
couple of weeks it's all well there's
another new one that I need now so final
well I want to speak to that though
because young research shows that people
can actually change the setting on their
hedonic treadmill okay and this and it
goes to what I was getting at earlier
about trait people can build trait
happiness and the external source that's
correct
of a spike of happiness like a new car
that tends to fade but as you repeatedly
internalize the feeling of the new car
or much more modest things like the
little accomplishments you you you do
every day as you internalize the feeling
of that more and more you build up a
very strong unconditional sense of
contentment
inside you so then as you face whether
to get the next car you know you think
about it and maybe you do need a new car
and you get a new car but it's not based
on an underlying lack or scarcity inside
which is the rid of
for want is you as you know you know
instead you meet the next pleasure
feeling already contented and that
really changes things it allows you to
see it with a much more unhindered
viewpoint I suppose as opposed to you
can eat this mindfulness gap again isn't
it so final final thing we're gonna
interview you're gonna run a little
experiment you're gonna sit down you're
gonna put them on the couch I know this
isn't your your way but you're gonna pop
it on the couch he's gonna be let's say
ten thousand ten thousand years ago just
before Agricultural Revolution
my great grandfather great great xxx
grandfather what do you think his mind
sets like if we're into a modern human
yeah I think the best comparison are
those you could call them Stone Age
Paleolithic hunter-gatherers in the
world today that are studied you know by
anthropologists and others and that's a
pretty good guess I think that he or she
was facing a lot of physical pain right
in the wild we're vulnerable to pain
myself age 66 so I've had things in my
body that probably would have killed me
you know 10,000 years ago word not for a
modern medicine so there's a certain
amount of pain food sources are not so
reliable maybe a certain amount of
hunger on the other hand I think that in
his mind he would feel much more
connected in community with his friends
and family there would be much more of a
bone deep felt sense of belonging and
being loved and then a typical person
probably experiences these days
loneliness is epidemic and it's
interesting research maybe you had other
people talk about it loneliness not like
I'm an introvert I like solitude because
that's yeah that's not being lonely
loneliness as a as a unpleasant
experience has roughly the equivalent
health consequences to smoking half a
pack of cigarettes a day
like that crazy in terms of impact yeah
chronic mortality morbidity a loneliness
imposes health burdens a lot of people
are lonely I don't think that
great-grandfather would feel lonely in
that way I think also that
great-grandfather would be spending less
time in a ruminator the simulator
there's a lot about life that even
though he has the same neural hardware
that we have today the same capacity to
go and the simulator when you're more in
the present moment in the nature of your
life as a hunter-gatherer and you're
also more in nature neurologically a
little cool hack the more you have a
sense of things as a whole including
your whole body or the whole physical
environment like in the rainforest or
the Serengeti plains the more you're in
nature that activates networks on the
sides of your brain which draw you into
a sense of wholeness and lower activity
in these midline neural networks that
are the neural basis for going into the
simulator going into these mini movies
so I think I think a grandfather would
be more you know dropped in to the
present moment okay those are my guesses
what are yours what do you think I don't
know so I think that I I definitely
agree grass and a better sense of
belonging I certainly know myself that
since in the last 18 months to two years
or so since I've started to take more
care with my sleep hygiene and try and
match I'm a club promoter by trade which
means that my sleeping patterns can
sometimes get slammed and yeah
accounting for that has made a big a big
difference being in nature certainly
makes a huge difference for me so I'd
agree
I'd agree on all of those points what's
interesting is I was thinking about
Maslow's hierarchy of needs as you were
talking about that there and it almost
it almost sounds like the bottom rungs
the need for warmth and food and so on
and so forth those ones are potentially
being less well met bun than the the
ones further up the pyramid are being
better met yeah
oddly enough interesting oddly enough
that's been flipped now I don't know
whether you'd agree with that in
Society I think that's deeply insightful
and really interesting and and you know
it's really poignant but well in other
words disappointed that so many people
lead lives of quiet desperation you know
to quote Thoreau and yet the typical
person this is a lower middle-class
working-class person even in the world
today lives better than the kings and
queens of a couple hundred years ago you
know so it's like what's her comparison
point but the opportunity going forward
to me is to realize that we really have
the power and it's about claiming the
power that you have it may sound
abstract for me it's extremely gritty
and down-to-earth and scruffy and
determined and self-reliant to claim the
power you have to shape your brain
everyday which really means shaping who
you are becoming everyday and as part of
that to claim your power to not be
manipulated by you know the forces in
society they want to make us hungry
ghosts because that's what's drives a
consumer culture and that's what makes
people docile with authoritarian leaders
and caught up in s against them
rivalries instead we have the power
every day to look for authentic
opportunities to feel safe enough
satisfied enough and connected enough
which is how to grow that strength
inside a resilient happiness Rick I
think that's a fantastic point too to
finish on I get the impression that
meaning you could have spent an awful
awful lot more time discussing this but
if the listeners want it enough and if
they want to drop me a message and let
me know I may be able to persuade you to
come back on but for now we are going to
have to call it a day there would you be
able to tell everyone who's listening
where they can find you online Chris has
been a pleasure I could keep going
myself simplest way to find me online is
Rick Hanson dotnet my name Rick Hanson
haan-soo Annette and that's the easiest
way to find my stuff
tons of freely offered material there
are lots of short clips videos audios
guided practices things you can do for
free to change your brain for the better
class have some neat online program
that are highly accessible grounded in
science you can check them out and if
anybody has any kind of financial need
issue we love giving scholarships we
love making our stuff available for free
so Rick Hanson net som fantastic well
the link to resilient how to grow an
unshakable core of calm strength and
happiness will be in the show notes
below as will the link to your website
Rick it's been a blast man thank you so
much for coming on I think everyone's
going to have learned an awful lot today
I hope so and I appreciate it I
appreciate you Chris for the ways you're
helping people it's a real service to
people what you're doing thank you very
much I'll catch you next time okay
[Music]